par marie claude bibeau ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'agroalimentaire
ottawa bonsoir madame bebo en sarre
monsieur monsieur gros lot 10 et 10 à 12
fois moins que ce qu'on attendait et
j'entendais un agriculteur albertain
dire aujourd'hui c'est comme verser un
seau d'eau sur un feu de forêt ce que
vous avez annoncé
il semble y avoir unanimité dans le
secteur agricole aujourd'hui pour dire
que c'est loin d'être assez mais c'est
un pote plus certainement et on cible
particulièrement le secteur des viandes
autant les producteurs que les
transformateurs je crois que ce niveau
là c'est certainement une aide
additionnelle significative mais c'est
important aussi leur applique le secteur
agricole a accès à ce qu'on appelle les
programmes de gestion de risque en
moyenne ces 1.6 milliards de dollars qui
est donné aux producteurs soudan dans le
cadre de différents programmes pour les
aider lorsqu'ils font face à des revenus
des pertes de revenus significatifs par
exemple alors ce programme-là ces
programmes là sont toujours disponibles
c'est des milliards de dollars qui sont
disponibles quand on est 100 millions
c'est des programmes qui sont faits en
cas de catastrophe naturelle
il ya des enveloppes à la performance
dans ça mais ici on parle d'une crise
exceptionnelle
on a l'impression d'un secteur agricole
que cet argent là que les programmes
existants sont pas vraiment fait pour la
crise qu'on vit présentement alors il ya
différents programmes y en a
effectivement qui vise les catastrophes
naturelles mais on a un autre agri
stabilité qui vise tout simplement la
perte de revenus significatifs alors on
s'entend on veut améliorer ces
programmes là qui est acquis ont été
coupés de façon très importante il ya
quelques années par le gouvernement
précédent
aujourd'hui pourquoi ne pas le faire
aujourd'hui madame bibeau les
agriculteurs c'est maintenant qu'ils
souffrent alors c'est ce sont des
programmes qui sont en partenariat avec
les provinces on a commencé à en
discuter mais il faut vraiment avoir
l'unanimité avec toutes les provinces
pour pouvoir augmenter le financement
dans ce cadre là alors ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui entre autres pour le secteur
des viandes c'est qu'on a pris un de ses
programmes aillerie relance et on a dit
bon le gouvernement du canada va donner
son sa contribution 60%
à toutes les provinces dans toutes les
provinces et on laisse la liberté à
chacune de décider si elles vont mettre
leur contribution de 40 % ou pas parce
qu'habituellement c'est vraiment une
entente une province à la fois donc le
sait on le fait on a pris une approche
différente pour le programme agri
relance justement pour pouvoir aller
plus heureusement malgré que les
provinces ne sont pas unanimes sur leurs
participations pourquoi le secteur
agricole demande deux milliards 600
millions et vous arrivez avec 2,2
milliards 600 millions et vous arrivez
avec 252 millions alors c'est un
spectacle un secteur plus
particulièrement qui est visé
aujourd'hui le secteur les producteurs
de porc et de boeuf et les
transformateurs aussi pour pouvoir
racheter surplus et les les envoyer dans
les banques alimentaires augmentation de
la capacité de prêt seulement pour la
commission canadienne du lait donc
différent ces programmes comme ça mais
encore une fois il faut rappeler que ces
programmes de gestion de risques
existent sont accessibles et on fait en
sorte de faciliter aussi l'accès par des
mesures administratives vous parler de
ces programmes de gestion de risques à
chaque fois qu'on vous pose la question
pour chaque fois on en parle aux
agriculteurs père l'union des
producteurs agricoles ils nous disent
c'est pas fait pour cette crise là
présentement aux états unis on est
arrivé avec un programme de 19 milliards
de l'aide directement américain 19
milliards envoyés aux producteurs aux
agriculteurs aux fermiers et dont 3
milliards pour racheter des viandes
racheter des surplus alimentaires
c'est beaucoup plus généreux est
beaucoup plus direct que ce que vous
annoncer aujourd'hui
oui je suis d'accord avec vous mais
c'est aujourd'hui c'est c'est une partie
du financement qu'on annonce est encore
une fois contrairement aux américains
on a des programmes qui existent déjà
qui sont là pour palier à différentes
situations
oui on veut être plus généreux mais
c'est quand même important d'aller
chercher cet argent qui est déjà sur la
table et le premier ministre l'a dit
clairement on veut être plus généreux
aussi donc c'est important d'identifier
où sont les manques entre les programmes
existants et les besoins exceptionnels
dus à la copie
est ce que tout le monde au conseil des
ministres puis au cabinet comprennent
bien l'importance du secteur agricole au
canada
oui on en parle très régulièrement c'est
sûr que la sécurité alimentaire c'est de
ça dont on parle sécurité alimentaire au
pays c'est extrêmement important on veut
aider nos producteurs dans tous les
secteurs
on veut aussi travailler sur notre
capacité de transformation sont notre
autonomie aussi dans une certaine mesure
parce qu'on a un secteur alimentaire qui
est extrêmement intégré avec les états
unis qui fonctionne bien on a fait très
attention de protéger la frontière aussi
pour que ça continue à circuler
correctement alors si un secteur qui est
extrêmement important pour notre
économie
les rachats qui sont annoncés de surplus
alimentaires on a mentionné les pommes
de terre et la volaille
ça vise principalement les pommes de
terre et la volaille pour les rachats de
surplus alimentaires pour les distribuer
dans les banques alimentaires
oui on peut parler aussi des champignons
prépare les du veau donc on va avoir une
discussion autant avec les grands
réseaux de banques alimentaires et aussi
avec les communautés dans le nord pour
voir quels sont leurs besoins on va
parler aussi avec les secteurs qui ont
le sait surplus pour voir de quelle
façon on peut faire l'arrimage parce que
c'est pas juste une question de
l'acheter il faut voir comment le
transport dans quel format aussi ça peut
servir les banques alimentaires alors
c'est assez complexe au niveau de la
logistique mais pas de rachat de porc ou
de boeuf a fait en une diminution de la
capacité de transformation en ce moment
donc le problème pour les producteurs
c'est qu'il n'arrive pas à envoyer leurs
animaux à l'abattoir à l' usine de
transformation parce que la capacité
réduite de façon significative et de
produits laitiers produits laitiers
c'est une possibilité d'une possibilité
86 pour ça je pense ces chiffres précis
des travailleurs étrangers qui sont
arrivés au canada par rapport à ce qu'on
avait connu l'année passée là on écrit
90 stands 85 et 90 pour ça il y en a une
partie qui sont pas arrivés et il ya des
graines qu'ils puissent pas arrivé parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tous les documents et
les activités administratives sont
ralenties qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour
le 10 ou 15% mon cas alors on réduit
le d'efforts on va essayer de compenser
dans les mois à venir dans les semaines
et les mois à venir parce que bon en ce
moment on peut compter aussi peut-être
sur un peu plus de main d'oeuvre
canadienne et québécoise mais bon d'ici
l'automne si les récoltes c'est possible
que ces gens-là retournent à leur
travail habituel retournent aux études
donc mais on va on redouble vraiment
d'effort et les résultats du mois
d'avril sont quand même très
encourageant merci madame bibeau pour
cet entretien ce soir merci à vous